A star-studded cast featuring Oscar winners
and icons, and an unusual premise dreamed
up by two unlikely collaborators. Here's what
you need to know about Peacock's "Poker Face."
Natasha Lyonne is probably best known for
playing the brash and combative Nicky Nichols
on Netflix megahit "Orange is the New Black."
More recently, Lyonne received recognition
for performance on Netflix's "Russian Doll,"
which she also co-created. The second season
of "Russian Doll" hit the streaming service
in April 2022, and Lyonne has hinted that
she'd like to wrap up the series in a third
season. While it's unclear whether or not
Netflix will renew the popular show, the New
York native already has her next role booked.
"Poker Face" is described as a
mystery-comedy-drama. Lyonne is set
to play Charlie Cale, a person with a knack for
deducing when someone isn't telling the truth.
As noted in a joint statement from Lyonne and
"Poker Face" creator Rian Johnson, via Deadline,
"Hello Miss Cale. I'm happy to finally meet you."
Lyonne and Johnson also clued potential
viewers into the show's genesis,
giving credit to a dinner conversation they
once shared. As their statement explained,
According to Deadline, the first season of
"Poker Face" will consist of 10 episodes. The
first four episodes will premiere on January
26, 2023, with subsequent chapters following
each week on Thursdays. In an interview on "Late
Night with Seth Meyers," Lyonne commented on the
difference between Netflix and broadcast
releases. Referring to "Orange is the New
Black," Lyonne discussed how quickly viewers
devoured shows that were dropped all at once.
"It's a 13-hour show. They consume it in
under 30 minutes flat. I don't know how
they do it. That's where I learned
about the space-time continuum."
Instead, Peacock's weekly release schedule will
hopefully have impatient fans on the edge of
their seats waiting for new installments. It
will also leave Lyonne's brain free to craft
new stories and not worry about the vagaries of
the universe and other metaphysical mysteries.
A slate of guest stars with familiar faces
are set to appear alongside Natasha Lyonne in
"Poker Face." According to Deadline, "Get Out"
star Lil Rel Howery will play a local sheriff,
and he'll be joined by "The Good Place" star
Jameela Jamil, Hollywood legends Ellen Barkin
and Nick Nolte, and "500 Hundred Days
of Summer" actor Joseph Gordon-Levitt.
Joining the already incredible cast is Lyonne's
"Orange Is the New Black" co-star Dascha Polanco,
Oscar winner Adrien Brody, "Miss Congeniality"
actor Benjamin Bratt, "Succession" star Cherry
Jones, filmmaker and fashion designer
Chloë Sevigny, former teen icon turned
director Clea DuVall, star of "Wednesday" Luis
Guzmán, and the original Hellboy, Ron Perlman.
"Knives Out" director Rian Johnson
will direct, write, and co-executive
produce "Poker Face" along with his frequent
collaborator Ram Bergman and Natasha Lyonne,
per Deadline. Lyonne and Johnson recently met at a
party and instantly clicked. She told Vanity Fair,
In a statement via TheWrap, Johnson said,
Lisa Katz, NBCUniversal Television and
Streaming's president of scripted
content, said in a statement,
Johnson and Lyonne will be joined as
co-executive producers by Maya Rudolph.